[Music]
when we talk about opioids we refer to
things like narcotics is another name
for opioids and this includes
medications like oxycodone or morphine
fentanyl there are many opioids and all
of them are used for pain and some of
them are natural occurring opioids such
as morphine and codeine and there are
some that are semi synthetic such as
hydrocodone oxycodone and hydromorphone
and then we have fully synthetic drugs
like methadone and fentanyl so all of
these drugs are used for both chronic
cancer pain and chronic non-cancer pain
as well as in some acute situations when
it's appropriate opioid use is a very
common medical treatment for pain and a
few other disorders if you need opioids
you should talk with your doctor about
that need and if it's specific to paying
for example you might ask whether there
are other pain relievers that are less
powerful that will still do the job if
you decide to undertake opioid treatment
with your physician I think it's very
important that you not exceed the
prescribed dose and the prescribed
frequency once you have taken opioids
for a while it's been important not to
stop without talking to your doctor and
developing a plan for reducing that use
pain is one of the most common things
that we treat in the emergency
department it's by far the most common
reason why patients present to the
emergency department we know that well
there's different studies but definitely
over fifty percent of patients present
because there's some sort of a pain that
could have been because they sprained
their ankle and that hurts or their
chest hurts or their abdomen hurts but
it's paint we as clinicians want to do
whatever we can to alleviate
pain this is this as part of our arm or
obligation we use medications like see
the medicine ibuprofen as best we can
but we do have this class of medications
which are the opioids even in the course
of my career probably starting around
two thousand or so there's started to be
this recognition that we were under
treating pain many studies came out that
showed that that we were allowing
patients to suffer needlessly we weren't
giving them adequate medication and this
led to lots of different standards that
happen there's an initiative that says
pain is the fifth vital sign for example
they started asking about pain treatment
on on satisfaction surveys that patients
got now they started using it as a
quality measure as well too so I think
that what happened was clinicians the
first inclination was to use the
medications that we knew worked for pain
and those are opioids they're the most
potent medications we have for pain and
so we started prescribing more and more
and I can tell you that we used to go
from one or two tylenol with codeine to
then using one or two tablets of
oxycodone to then using lots of
hydromorphone a really strong opioid and
we started using more and more at a time
to the point where the pendulum
definitely swung too far to the side of
overtreatment and now we're we're in
this phase right now it's not just the
emergency physicians it's we know that
it's it's basically all clinicians we
know that the prescribing of opioids
increased markedly probably at least
four fold if you look at the actual
numbers of milligrams probably tenfold
over the past 20 years and so now we're
in this area where we are right now I
think I think the the current strategy
that we have at least in the emergency
department is to minimize the use of
opioids as much as possible so we do try
and use see the minocin ibuprofen we use
patches that have lidocaine that help
with the symptoms we're trying to do do
better a better job with regional blocks
these are where we inject a little bit
of anesthetic around a nerve and this
can make the pain for that area
completely go away for a significant
amount of time we're also recognizing
that we still need to use opioids in
some situations but we don't need to use
so much we now know that a cute
really severe pain probably laughs only
two to three days and so there's no
point in getting a prescription with 30
pills it's prone it's probably
sufficient to have eight or ten pills
because we know that there's left over
20 pills then stay in the medicine
cabinet they get diverted they get
abused and that's where people get into
trouble so I think that there's this new
recognition about the the problem and I
think there's a new sophistication with
how a reason these medications as well
in addition to multimodal pain treatment
that's using every opportunity we have
to treat pain before we reach for the
opioid frequently in the emergency
department when someone has pain they
want to feel better and sometimes they
fit quite feeling better with the opioid
medication in this new era of
sophistication where we're trying to be
very good about how we're using opioids
we're trying to reduce their utilization
as much as possible but sometimes tricky
patients want to have the strong
medication you want a certain amount but
we know that there's harm associated
with it if a patient comes in and they
are requesting an opioid I now sit down
with the patient to have a discussion we
have good research that came out that
showed that if you have back pain and
you get an opioid your outcomes are
exactly the same at five days as if you
hadn't had the opioid so what's the
point of having the risk of that
medication we know that if you maximize
the non opioid medications ibuprofen
acetaminophen pain patches like
lidocaine patches for example then often
people will feel entirely better so why
do I take the risk of the opioid the
number that sticks in my head that I
often tell patients is fifteen percent
I've seen that over and over again in
many studies whether it be risk of my
nurse or having minor surgery getting a
first prescription for an opioid naive
patient in the emergency department aims
at about fifteen percent of them will
still be on opioids at a year even if
they're opioid naive before and that was
their very first prescription so I tell
patients about fifteen percent of
patients that I give that first
prescription to will still be dependent
on minute a year it's not worth the risk
in most cases so when treating pain
opioids are extremely powerful and there
is clearly a role for them the problem
that we have currently is that
practitioners are literally all over the
map
some people will not prescribe anything
at any for any condition and some people
will give 30 60 90 pills of oxycodone or
hydrocodone and so I think what's
happening is that we're creating a
severe so severe problem of expectations
for patients because they don't know
what they're going to get from which
doctor we need to do a better job with
that we're starting to see guidelines
that are coming up such as from the CDC
which need guidelines we need to get on
the same page even after procedures for
example after a normal childbirth or a
cesarean section we found that if
situations are extremely varied with
with the numbers of pills that they give
for patients we see that after
orthopedic surgery as well after after
general surgery like appendicitis for
example some people will give no opioids
and will give a lot of opioids and it's
that this is creating a problem so we
need some some form of standardization
obviously we need to recognize that
every patient is different and their
needs will be different but we can't
have this this tenfold difference in the
amount of pain medications that are
given to people the thing that I'm most
concerned about no it's not just it's
not the treatment of acute pain it's
what's left over with Silver's leftover
pills that are in the medicine cabinet
because we know that the vast majority
of patients people that non-medical use
opioids they get them from a friend or
family for free and what that means is
that there were medications that were
prescribed that were left over we need
to do a better job with right sizing
those prescriptions and I think we're
starting to do that and my own Hospital
we actually just are speaking about
getting all the specialties that
prescribed talking about their most
common most frequent procedures and then
getting all the faculty on the same page
as far as what what the guidance will be
for how many pills should be prescribed
and the good thing about this is that
they often emphasized non opioids first
and the opioids only for the severe pain
if the other medications and other
modalities are not working despite all
the attention given to not prescribing
opioids and to reuse reduce our
utilization of opioids that's that they
clearly have a role in it in the
environment where I practice we often
see patients with severe chest pain
abdominal pain bad infections
particularly trauma fractures for
example so it's clear from some of these
problems that the patients can have
fractures severe trauma abdominal pains
even even cancer a chronic pain there is
certainly a role for opioids